>> THAT SATCHEL.
GREAT REPORTING ED HENRY, THANKS
SO MUCH.
WE WILL BE WATCHING, 9-NOON
EASTERN.
NOW BACK TO THE LATEST ELEMENTS.
IF YOU’VE BEEN PAYING ATTENTION
THIS AFTERNOON, THERE IS A
PASSIONATE DEBATE UNDERWAY RIGHT
NOW.
BUT THERE SHOULDN’T BE A DEBATE
BECAUSE THERE ISN’T ACTUALLY A
DEBATE ABOUT WHY THE CASE WAS
DROPPED.
DOJ OFFICIALS EXPLAINED IT IN
DETAIL TODAY.
READ THE FILINGS, IT’S WORTH IT,
THEY ARE ONLINE.
CLEARLY ALMOST NO ONE COMMENTING
ON THE CASE HAS READ THEM, AND
THEY SHOULD.
THE DOCUMENTS ARE SHOCKING NOT
FOR REPUBLICANS OR DEMOCRATS BUT
FOR AMERICANS.
WE HAVE OUTLINED MUCH OF WHAT WE
KNEW ABOUT THE FLYNN CASE, AND
HOW AN FBI DIRECTOR DECIDED TO
DERAIL HIM.
AT ONE POINT, PETER STRZOK
DECIDED TO CHARGE FLYNN UNDER
SOMETHING CALLED THE LOGAN ACT.
IN THE ENTIRE SPAN OF AMERICAN
HISTORY HAS NEVER BEEN USED TO
CONVICT AND SINGLE PERSON.
IN FACT NO ONE HAS BEEN INDICTED
UNDER THE LOGAN ACT SINCE BEFORE
THE CIVIL WAR.
IN FACT IS PROBABLY
UNCONSTITUTIONAL.
BUT PETER STRZOK DIDN’T CARE,
HIS GOAL WAS TO KEEP THE
INVESTIGATION GOING.
BY JANUARY 4TH 2017 THE FBI HAD
COMPLETED ITS INVESTIGATION OF
FLYNN WHICH WAS THOROUGH.
THEY FOUND "NO DEROGATORY
INFORMATION OF ANY KIND LINKING
FLYNN TO RUSSIA.
THAT WOULD HAVE ENDED RIGHT
THERE.
ACCORDING TO THE DOJ TODAY, IT
SHOULD HAVE ENDED.
THERE WAS FOR COMMUNICATING THE
FOREIGN INVESTIGATOR.
THAT’S THE ESSENCE OF IT RIGHT
THERE.
PEOPLE CANNOT COMMIT A CRIME AND
THEY KNEW IT.
ITSELF IS A SHOCKING OUTRAGE AND
COMPLETELY UNACCEPTABLE IN A
FREE COUNTRY.
FOR SOME REASON NOBODY IN
WASHINGTON SEEMS TO NOTICE OR
CARE ABOUT, BUT THEY SHOULD.
BECAUSE THEY ALREADY KNEW WHAT
FLYNN HAD SAID IN THE CALL, NO
JUSTIFICATION OR NEED TO ASK HIM
ABOUT HIS OWN PERSONAL
RECOLLECTIONS OF WHAT HAD BEEN
SAID BECAUSE THEY KNEW.
WE KNOW THIS FOR CERTAIN BECAUSE
WE HAVE PETER STRZOK’S TEXT
MESSAGES TO HIS CREEPY
GIRLFRIEND.
THE FBI CLAIMED THEY HAD BEEN
LOST DUE TO SOME TECHNICAL
GLITCH SO WE ALMOST DID FIND OUT
WHAT EXACTLY HAPPENED.
MICHAEL FLYNN ALMOST WENT TO
PRISON.
AND THAT GETS TO THE NUB OF ALL
OF THIS.
HOW OFTEN DOES THE FBI SET
PEOPLE UP?
HOW MANY OTHER LIVES HAVE THEY
DESTROYED WITHOUT THE PUBLIC
KNOWING ABOUT IT?
THIS ISN’T ABOUT MICHAEL FLYNN,
IT’S ABOUT YOU.
IT’S SCARY TO THINK ABOUT THAT.
MOST PEOPLE IN WASHINGTON SEEMED
DETERMINED NOT TO THINK ABOUT
IT, THEY ARE INTENT ON EXCUSING
ALL OF THIS.
ILHAN OMAR WAS THE AMONG THE
FIRST TO CHIME IN ON THE NEWS,
WHITE PRIVILEGE AT WORK.
OMAR DIDN’T EXPLAIN WHAT IN THE
WORLD MAKE FLYNN’S CASE MIGHT
HAVE TO DO WITH HIS SKIN COLOR
WHICH YOU CAN’T CONTROL.
BUT SHE DENOUNCED THE DECISION
IS RACIST ANYWAY.
SURPRISED?
YOU SHOULDN’T BE SURPRISED.
ILHAN OMAR CLEARLY MARRIED HER
OWN BROTHER IN AN IMMIGRATION
SCAM.
SHE PASSIONATELY HATES THE
COUNTRY THAT SAVED HER.
AND CAN A SINGLE HUMAN BEING
ACTUALLY BE AS LOW SOME?
SHE’S LIKE A PARODY OF HER
IMPULSIVENESS.
WE CAN SAY WITH CONFIDENCE THE
RNC DID NOT CREATE CABLE NEWS.
THE DUMMIES THERE ARE ALMOST AS
ANGRY AS ILHAN OMAR WAS.
WATCHED JEB BUSH’S FORMER FLAK
TO TALK TO THE REST OF US ABOUT
SMEAR CAMPAIGNS.
>> MIKE FLYNN’S LAWYERS HAVE
BEEN ENGAGED IN A SMEAR CAMPAIGN
VERY, VERY SIMILAR COME UP OUT
OF THE SAME PLAYBOOK, FROM THE
SAME FBI LEADER.
>> THE IDEA THAT THEY COULD DO
THIS, THIS IS THE COLLAPSE OF
THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT.
THIS IS APOLITICAL AND
INCREDIBLY DESTRUCTIVE THING.
>> IT’S NOT GOOD FOR MORALE AND
IS NOT A FAIR OUTCOME IN THIS
CASE.
>> TODAY WITH SEEING THE
POLITICAL CORRUPTION OF THE
JUSTICE SYSTEM THAT MIKE FLYNN
HAS LONG BEEN CALLING FOR.
THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT HAVE
NOTHING TO DO WITH IT.
>> THIS IS AN ABSOLUTE INJUSTICE
INJUSTICE.
>> Tucker: SO WHAT EXACTLY ARE
THESE PEOPLE SAYING?
THEY SUGGESTED THEIR GOAL WAS TO
"GET HIM TO LIE SO WE CAN
PROSECUTE HIM OR GET HIM FIRED.
IT’S NOT SPECULATION, THE FBI
WROTE THAT DOWN ON PAPER.
FLYNN FACED A MAXIMUM OF FIVE
YEARS IN PRISON.
OUR PEOPLE REALLY ARGUING THAT
HIS PROSECUTION WAS A
LEGITIMATE?
ARE THEY REALLY ARGUING THEY
SHOULD BE BEHIND BARS?
WOULD HAPPEN TO THEIR COMMITMENT
TO CIVIL RIGHTS AND FAIRNESS?
THERE’S NOTHING LIBERAL ABOUT
THE ARGUMENTS THEY ARE MAKING,
THIS IS THE MOST BRUTAL KIND OF
POWER POLITICS DISGUISED WITH
ALLIES.
THIS MOMENT REPRESENTS THE FULL
COLLAPSE OF AN APOLITICAL
JUSTICE DEPARTMENT, WROTE CNN’S
LEGAL ANALYST.
JUSTICE MATTHEW MILLER AGREED
WITH THAT "BAR IS GIVING
TREATMENTS THAT ARE NOT -- THEY
WERE COORDINATED, THE WORLD’S
ANGRIEST FORMER LABOR SECRETARY
ROBERT RICE WROTE THIS "UNDER
WILLIAM BARR’S STEWARDSHIP, THE
JUSTICE DEPARTMENT HAS BECOME
NOTHING MORE THAN A POLITICAL
TOUR FOR TRUMP TO BILL AGAINST
HIS ENEMIES AND DRAW AGAINST HIS
FRIEND.
PAUSE AND CONSIDER THIS.
IT’S THE OPPOSITE OF WHAT’S
TRUE.
DROPPING THE CASE AGAINST
MICHAEL FLYNN MEANS JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT IS NOW A POLITICAL
TOOL?
NO.
THE ATTORNEY GENERAL DROPPED THE
CASE THIS IS A POLITICAL TOOL TO
REMOVE THE NATIONAL SECURITY
ADVISOR.
THAT’S THE WHOLE POINT.
NO HONEST PERSON CAN REACH ANY
OTHER CONCLUSION.
READ THE DOCUMENTS YOURSELF.
BUT THESE ARE NOT HONEST PEOPLE.
THEY BASE SLICKLY AT DENOUNCED
THE POLITICAL OPPONENTS AS
RUSSIAN AGENTS.
ADAM SCHIFF WEIGHED IN AS WELL
AND HE COULDN’T HELP HIMSELF.
"FLYNN FELT GUILTY TO THE FBI
ABOUT HIS ILLICIT RUSSIAN
CONTACTS.
THIS DISMISSAL DOES NOT
EXONERATE HIM.
THE CHAIRMAN OF THE HOUSE
INTELLIGENCE COMMITTEE NOW SAYS
THAT THE CALL BETWEEN THE
NATIONAL SECURITY ADVISOR AND
RUSSIAN AMBASSADOR TO THE
UNITED STATES IS "AN ILLICIT
RUSSIAN CONTACT?
HE IS CLAIMING THAT.
THIS IS INSANITY AND ITS
CALCULATED INSANITY.
IN THE END, I HATE TO TELL YOU,
IT MAY WORK.
AND THAT’S WHY THEY ARE SAYING
IT.
IN THE MEANTIME, WHAT SHOULD IT
MEAN IF UNSCRUPULOUS LIARS LIKE
THESE WERE TO TAKE FULL CONTROL
OF THE COUNTRY?
THEY KNOW MICHAEL FLYNN IS NOT A
DANGEROUS CRIMINAL.
IF HE WAS A DANGEROUS CRIMINAL
THEY WOULD BE WORKING TO FREE
HIM FROM JAIL.
THEY WANTED HIM CRUSHED, AND HE
MOCKS THEM TO THEIR FACES AND
THAT DIMINISH THEIR AUTHORITY.
ROGER STONE MAY STILL GO TO
PRISON BY THE WAY, WE WILL KEEP
YOU POSTED.
HOW MANY OTHER INCONVENIENT
AMERICANS COULD A BANKRUPT AND
IMPRISON IF THEY COULD?
THIS IS AN OFFENSE AGAINST EQUAL
JUSTICE THEY SCREAM TO THE
CAMERA.
RIGHT, THE VERY SAME PEOPLE WHO
DEMAND THEY AFTER DAY THAT THEY
HOLD AMERICAN CITIZENS TO
COMPLETELY DIFFERENT STANDARDS
BASED ON HOW THEY LOOK?
NOW THEY ARE TELLING YOU,
JUSTICE MUST BE BLIND.
THE ESSENCE OF FAIRNESS IN EVERY
COUNTRY AT EVERY TIME IS
FAIRNESS.
WITH THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT DID
TO MIKE FLYNN WAS DEMONSTRABLY